des policiers se justifie après les
violences contre les gilet jaune dans un
burger king et les procès verbaux des
agents mise en examen fin voix ont fuité
dans le parisien aujourd'hui en france
des faits qui remontent au rappel au 1er
décembre 2018 et après 18 mois d'enquêté
menée par l'igpn à l'un des policiers
évoquent un contexte de chaos inédit d
agression par des adversaires à
radicaliser
on en parle justement avec joanne caza
d'héroïne et délégué national crs du
syndicat alliance bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
18 mois d'enquêté menée par l'igpn et
quatre policiers ont finalement été mis
en examen
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que ce qu'on connaissait jusqu'à présent
c'est-à-dire que quand les tiens est-ce
interviennent sur de petits troubles à
l'ordre public
il s'ennuie t constitué on ne va jamais
rechercher l'individu elle donc qu'est
ce qui change c'est que dorénavant ça a
changé la méthode d'une métier lord
qu'on va rechercher la responsabilité
individuelle des fonctionnaires ce qui
est nouveau on va dire on verra ce qu'il
enquête est toujours en cours il faut
pas non plus que les collègues soient
les boucs émissaires il ya toute une
chaîne de commandement avec des gens qui
ont décidé de la renvoyer au bo gars qui
tu leur en donner des consignes de
fermeté d'évacuer le burger king très
rapidement voilà donc nous il est hors
de question ce soit les collègues qu'ils
soient les seuls mis en examen pour
l'instant on verra à l'issue d'un procès
est ce qu'on l'a clara blocs pour se
défendre
en tout cas pour nous c'est inconcevable
que les seules collecte sur le terrain
qu'ils soient concernés oui parce que ce
que vous dites c'est vrai qu'il ya
certains qui ont été entendues et qui
ont dit on a écouté l essor
quand on nous a donné qu est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'il ya un
problème au niveau de la hiérarchie
qu'on a un peu laissé gens me dire les
crs comme ça on n'aura pas donné d'ordre
ni de directives précises les directives
les ordres étaient précise-t-elle évacué
très rapidement le burger king
mais comme à chaque fois de toute
manière lorsqu'il est intéressant de
police ou ceux du maintien d'ordre ou
autre on a toujours les harrachis qui
est au dessus qu'ils aient jamais avec
qui j'avais impactés alors que peut-être
ce jour là il ya peut-être eu des
erreurs de commandement
je rappellerai qu'on a laissé jean
compagnies de crs le 1er décembre en
garde statique
là aussi ça peut être été une faute fort
à pourvoir avec trois compagnies qui
manoeuvrait mais il est trop facile une
fois de plus de se retourner contre les
agents qui font qui reçoit des ordres
qu'ils exécutent et sans que certains
soit exonéré de responsabilités ça ce
n'est pas tolérable
alors si je comprends bien on des papas
sur le fait qu'il y a eu des
des violences sont les a vus sur la
vidéo et qui même les policiers
incriminés j'ai envie de dire ont
reconnu les faits on débat pour savoir
pourquoi ils l'ont fait et est ce que
vraiment il y avait un problème au
niveau de la hiérarchie est ce qu'on
leur a donné cet ordre là de frapper les
manifestants
les violences on vend effectivement
quand on connaît pas les images peuvent
être choquantes mais après dans le
contexte de la journée avec s'explique
ou alors ensuite il ya des ordres quand
vous dites il ya d autres ont été
données on nous on aimerait bien savoir
qui a donné les ordres
comment ça se passe ça s'est passé
pourquoi cette compagnie alors que
pendant 16 heures
elle a subi des assauts à la utilisé
depuis 2000 relate cette compagnie est
vraiment été mis au coeur de dispositifs
prendre pour le décembre il était sous
la douche triomphe quand il a été
attaqué devant derrière ils ont été pris
en tenaille
voilà donc il faut pas non plus oublier
qu'il ya toute une chaîne et comprendre
et essayer de voir ce qu'il ya eu comme
comme erreur pour justement ne pas s'en
servir est hors de question ce sont
vraiment que les collègues qui exécute
les ordres donnés d'évacuer très
rapidement le burger king qui ne soit
concerné alors comment on peut expliquer
que les procès verbaux et un peu fuité
dans la presse ça je ne sais pas c'est
dommage parce que ça peut pas se
retrouver dans la presse maintenant on
verra il en a beaucoup je pense qu'il
peut être plus à même que moi de
s'exprimer sur leurs affaires voilà moi
je reste vraiment dans le contexte
policier qu'on va nous de connaissances
après je pense leur avocat sera plus à
même de s'expliquer sur ces affaires
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous
sur rt france monsieur cavallero merci
beaucoup